hey peyton manning's continued to reject
all overtures from tv most recently he
said no to monday night football again
and peyton manning has talked about why
he didn't do it and charles robinson of
yahoo had a report over the weekend
about why peyton didn't do it bottom
line is he doesn't want to have to
analyze slash criticize his brother eli
manning and also for the first time this
notion of peyton manning not wanting to
have to analyze and criticize former
teammates is coming to the fore and i
get it i respect that now look
i think there's a way to do the job
without
saying things that could anger people
but i respect peyton manning's
desire to do the job right and the only
way you do the job right is if you say
what you believe even if that means
potentially pissing some people off and
i know from experience 19 years in what
i do you
pretend to piss a lot of people off if
you tell what you think is the truth
peyton manning wants to be able when he
does take a tv job if he ever takes a tv
job to say what he believes to tell the
truth as he sees it and uh to not have
to worry about the consequences whatever
they may be so
peyton manning at least will continue to
say no to tv until his brother retires
and then after that he may wait for a
few former teammates to walk away and
ultimately you know he mentioned jets
coach adam gase because he worked
closely with him in denver it could be
that he waits until gases in coaching
before peyton manning jumps into tv
either way tv is always going to be
there they're not going to turn their
back on peyton manning whenever he's
ready to go there will be one or more
networks ready to move heaven and earth
and pay him a crapload of money and let
him dictate the terms of who the
broadcast team will be and who he'll be
working with and what he'll be doing all
in the hopes of getting peyton manning
as part of that network's coverage
because the belief is he'll be the best
ever better than john madden better than
tony romo better than anybody if and
when peyton manning finally chooses to
do it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports